okay I guess uh let's get started
this is working right yeah so
um I guess last time where we
um and that end up with was
um
so we talked about you know this view
that
that you view the function class f
um in some sense as equivalent to a set
queue right so if you have a function
class F and you can Define this Q to be
the set of vectors
of this form or basically the output
vector which is a vector in RN
and here f is changing over the class F
right so in some sense for the random
one complexity perspective these two
objects are not very different right so
the random the important complexity of f
only depends on Q
and also we have talked about the case
when you have a find and Q
of find an F in some sense and sometimes
actually even you have infinite F you
can have finite queue in some cases but
not very technical
um but in this case what you can show is
that you can have a random marker
complexity Bank
um this is the so-called masala
so we're saying that
um if your queue satisfies that
this is the at the end of the last
lecture so suppose for every Vector in Q
we have that
this Norm of the queue normalized by
while we're squared in is less than n
then
we know that this quantity
which is essentially the right marker
complexity of
f is bounded by this
2 times M Square Times log of the size
of Q
over n
so
um and if you translate this back to the
function class then you know that
if
satisfies
that
forever having us
this
I've responded in average by m right
this this you can view this as an
average size of app but it's a quadratic
mean but now that later the mean uh and
then you have that
the random marker complexity of this
function class f is bounded by 2m Square
log of the size of f
over it
so and
so in this time we're going to deal with
the case where you don't have a finite
hypothesis class
right so if you have infinite hypothesis
infinite Q or F then what do you do
and what we're going to do is that we're
going to do a disqualization but now
we're discretizing in the
in the queue space or the auto space of
f
so before I think you know in one of the
previous lectures we discretized in the
parameter space and now we are going to
discretize in this more fundamental
space to Optical space because as we
kind of argue that output space of the
is what's really fundamentally important
the parametrization is just something
that influenced the output space but if
you have the same output space but
different parametrization actually the
functions class are not different so so
the parametrization are not the most
fundamental thing here so so what we're
going to do is we're going to discretize
the output space
and
um
so
so the so and we still have this idea of
epson this concept
of epson cover so now we are going to
cover the offspace output space Q or
output space of f by the so-called Epson
cover
let's recall a definition of Epsilon
cover so recall that the definition was
that c is Epsilon cover
of Q now I'm using I'm talking about
Epsilon cover of q but I just changed
the variable I think before we call it
absolute power of some other set
so with respect to some Matrix
rho if for any Vector in q
there exists a
Vector in C that covers it and by covers
it it means that
such that
the distance between this Vector is less
than absolute
and let me also Define the so-called
covering number
which is the quantity we're going to
uh use very frequently so the cover
number of
foreign
like there are several arguments one
thing is the the target radius the
target
um radius Epsilon and also the third Q
and the magic row this is defined to be
the minimum
size
of Epsilon cover
of Q with respect to real
right so this is the minimal possible
size of the covering
um and
and
so
sorry there's a so how so and in some
sense we can use this carbon number in
after two ways one way is you talk about
the covering of Q and the other way you
can talk about carving of f right so uh
even though I think the fundamental
thing is about the queue I think in the
literature you know if you read the
paper then in most of cases people talk
about covering of the you know the
function at least in many papers so
we're going to use that language but but
they are essentially the same so so
basically
um let's first color so if you do this
for the covering of f then it's the same
thing so if you have Epsilon cover
of the function class F you just view f
as a as a function class so then it is
saying that you know
uh satisfies that
for every F in capital F there exists F
Prime such that u f f Prime is less than
absolute so it's just a literally the
same thing
um and also we're going to choose the
row uh to be the same you know for like
it's like a like a 4k1 f so basically
what we're going to do is that we're
going to choose row uh between two
vectors right in the Q in the cube
perspective you choose this to be one
over square root n times
uh the L2 distance recall that both V
and V Prime are Dimension eigenvector in
Space RN so this is basically out sorry
into there's no Square so basically this
is a normalized version of the L2
distance the reason we normalize by over
square root n is just because this is
more consistent
um you know the normalization
fundamentally doesn't matter first of
all right so whatever normalization you
choose it doesn't change the essence and
the reason why we choose a normalization
here is just simply for consistency with
um the function space view where you
have a two functions then you define a
row to be
suppose you have two functions F and F
Prime and what's the distance between
them recall that you know we only
restrict our function on the file and
set of points zero to zero and so the
typical definition of the distance would
just be the L2 distance on the set of
points so it's just something like you
look at the average
difference between these two functions
on zis
and then you you take the quadratic
average
and then you take the
um basically called jacket average of
the difference between F and F Prime
onset of CIS and you can see that these
are exactly the same row
um just a view you can view them in
either the function space or you can
view it in the uh the vector space
and typically people write this row as
row to
PN so so the reason I guess you know for
those who are not familiar with just a
Sim compass
arbitrary conflict symbols to indicate
this but for those of you who are a
little bit more familiar with some of
this function analysis so I think the
idea is that p n this is the empirical
distribution
basically uniform
over Z1 up to zero
and L2
of PM means that you have a L2 metric
defined on this empirical distribution
this uniform Distribution on the on the
script but if you don't know
where these come from like no no right
this is just a let's just treat it as an
abstract note like um symbol just
because you know I'm gonna use this
simple several times just for formality
um but it really just means this
[Music]
um
Okay so
so and you know with this view basically
you know as we as we have said right so
you have a f you know corresponds to q
and a function f corresponds to this
vector
FZ1 up to fzn
in Q and and it's a one-to-one
correspondence also the row corresponds
to each other so you can in some sense
write this tribute and the
correspondence
if you look at the function space view
with the metric row then is the carbon
number is the same as you view it in the
output
in the in the output space the vector
space and you use the metric normalized
L2 naught and one of the reasons why we
normalize about well and by something
that depends on it is just because you
have any Dimension and any something
that's changing so in some sense it
makes sense to normalize by that because
if you have a chain Vector with changing
dimension sometimes it's hard to compare
different cases so that's why you want
to have a norm that doesn't depend on
dimensionality
and from now on we're going to write the
the function space view like notation we
are going to write in the the the F
notation but
in my mind I'm always thinking about
Optical space because that's that's just
a vector space which is much easier to
think about
okay so and also I you know the the
formal kind of like a theorem will be
stating in the function space but
um
but when I approve it I'm going to
change to the queue just to make it more
kind of explicit
and here's a theorem that kind of deal
with the
in some sense this is a kind of like a
trivial discretization
what we're going to do is that we're
going to first discuss this and then
have a more advanced statisticalization
which is called chaining so the trivial
version is the following which is in
some sense basically
um
um
basically the same as like in spirit the
same as what we have done in lecture
three but here we are doing the function
space so let FB
of family
of functions
from some space z to
minus one one so I will show that these
functions to be bounded between -1 1
and then for every Epsilon larger than
zero
you can show The Following
so the body marker complexity is less
than Epsilon Plus
let me write it down and they interpret
it log of the carbon number
with the radius Epsilon
over n
and we're going to show you know how to
prove this and when you show how to
prove when we prove it you know you'll
see that this is in some sense the
discretization error
and this is in some sense from the
random complexity of the of the the
finance Epson cover
so
um we'll see this more clearly in the
proof
so in sometimes the general idea is that
you approximate to the
the proof the general idea is that
your approximate
F by
by an Epson cover
and
maybe let's and let's call C and then
maybe let's not give a name so but I
have some cover and then when you have
the Epson cover uh for the Epson cover
you have a random marker complexity
bound and then you pay something because
of the discretization or the
approximation
Okay so and when we prove it as I said
you know I tend to kind of change it to
the vector space view just because then
you don't need any all of those kind of
like function uh on drugging about
function space so let's
um
let's
let's see be an Epsilon cover
of Clue
Q is the output space where Q is the
same thing right so then let's say this
is such the size
which is equals to the minimum carbon
number right
which is just the same as
as we claimed
of the function class so I know
um
Okay so
now if you look at the random marker
complexity of the function as we claim
that this is in some sense the same as
the complexity of the
output set
and now what you do is you say I'm going
to approximate V by the nearby point in
the cover right so so suppose you have
the set queue
and I have a vector v and I know that V
is covered by something right
you have some cover like this
you know that this point V is covered by
for example this point V Prime
in in the set C
right every every Point C recall that
every Point C because
um to cover a certain family of Pawns
right it can cover six Neighbors in some
radius and and you and you know that
every Point can be covered by some
Vector in C so when the vector B can be
covered by V Prime let's say so then you
know that V and V Prime
the distance is less than absolute and
then you can approximate so for every V
find V Prime in C and you know that
distance is less than Epsilon and also
you can write these Sigma in some sense
distribute as
V Prime Sigma plus v minus V Prime Sigma
right maybe let's call this Z
So it's b Prime Sigma
plus Z times Sigma
right and what you know is that Z is
small so because the distance right so
you know Z
in this distance recall that we are
using a scaled L2 Norm
so this is less than Epsilon this is
what we know
so then what we know that Z times Sigma
you can use the uh I think this is one
which this is cautious right so
the inner product of two vectors is less
than
the norm of the two vectors the two Norm
of the two vectors so this is less than
squared
in times Epsilon times
the norm of the sigma which is n times
F2
right so so basically we know that this
error term is less than Epsilon by doing
this and then uh so now we can go back
to the random marker complexity
you first use this uh
um
uh
so this is just the less than
expectation
using this uh a few things right so
less than up song right because Z in a
paradigm with Sigma is less than Epsilon
and this Epsilon can be go outside of
all of those things because Epsilon is a
constant so then you get
plus absolute and here what's the range
of V Prime so V Prime always has to be
in C right there's no way like this is
the our definition of v Prime V Prime is
the the cover in C so then
if you can see this I guess this is
equality sorry
and then uh
and then this one
you can use the Masala lemon this is the
complexity of the set C the cover set C
is using my cell Lemma you get square
root two log C Over N plus Epsilon
um
and and we are done right C has this
size
so this is just the square root 2 log
an Epsilon fl2pm
of M plus Epsilon
okay so pretty simple
um and any questions so far
okay
so now let's talk about stronger theorem
and this is a in my opinion pretty deep
zero because
at least you know I probably I don't
have much inclusion about it but you
know hopefully after you I show the
proof you know it's intuitive but it is
something non-tribute and this is
generally this type of technique is
called chaining
uh and they could be much more ways to
do this kind of training in such
different situations so here I'm
um here the the particular theorem is
called Dudley serum Dudley
that laser
so the theorem is saying that
um so
so let F be
of family of functions
from Z to R
so here actually I relax this even
because this theorem is more General it
can work more even you know functions
that are not bounded and
so
The Watermark complexity is Bound By The
Following
let me write it down it it doesn't look
very intuitive in the beginning but I
will explain
so it's integral
so the variable is Epsilon so you are
integrating
a function of Epsilon from 0 to Infinity
and you look at the cover number
for different Epson and you divide by
uh and
so so the integrand is square root of
the log of the carbon number over square
rooted
so and the first step you know it's not
even clear whether this is a stronger
serum than before because you know
um it's not cheaper to compare with the
previous one but actually you can
compare if you do some work
um so so probably you know what I'm
going to do is I'm going to show the
proof
um and then I'm going to interpret this
because you know I think from the proof
it's it's pretty obvious that you're
gonna get a stronger statement uh but if
you just compare the form you know it's
not that you know tribute to compare but
from the proof you can see that this is
like the proof techniques the extension
of the previous proof technique and you
should kind of like
it's pretty obvious that you should
expect a stronger theorem and then you
know later I'm going to compare them and
also interpret this because you know
this form by itself is still somewhat
kind of like hard to hard to use right
how do we know whether I can integrate
something good out of this right so so
I'm going to you know give you some
several cases where you can integrate a
good number out of this integration
so that's the part
um
all right so so now let's dive into the
proof lecture so how do we prove this
and what's intuition so let's start with
the intuition the intuition is that
um
this is actually probably one of the
pretty technical proof
in in this in this course so
um
so intuition is that you have this
um
as I'm I'm thinking about whether I
should draw a single figure I've I've
drawn a lot of figures on the on my
lecture notes but I think it's going to
be challenging for the scrap note takers
to
produce all of them in this notes so I'm
thinking if I should draw one
yeah maybe I'll drop multiple on the
latest Scrabble takers to figure out how
to merge them if they want
um so the intuition is let me draw this
again so
so you have this set queue
and what we have done was that you
create a cover
Epsilon cover
right it covers this and every sensor is
one point in C and you want all of these
you know balls to cover your set
right so and what we have done was that
you have a vector v
here
and and you say that I'm going to
approximate V by V Prime
and plus the distance
so basically your approximately V by V
prime plus the this the difference in z
so
um so this is all fine the problem is
that you know how do you so you have
this
formula let me just write again
so the tricky thing is that how do you
deal with this error Z times Sigma right
so what we did before was that we have a
very Brute Force inequality saying that
this is less than two Norm of Z times
two Norm of Sigma
over and when this can happen this can
happen only if Z is perfectly correlated
with Sigma which just cannot happen
always
right because Z is a vector which is the
difference between V and V Prime this it
could be correlated with Sigma you know
you know if your ball is you know if it
so by the way this ball is like a
you know I draw it like a ball but this
is this could be of different shape
right because if every all the
everything is really a ball right so
suppose this is really just a cleaning
body everything will become too trivial
for us right so Q is the set and there
is some Metric defined on it and this
metric is potentially somewhat
complicated which we don't really know
the metric is uh sorry like a sorry the
metric is Trivial but the the set itself
is could be complicated because you
don't really know what a side looks like
right it's the image of a function on
some set of vectors on set of points
right so so this this set is uh these
are all balls but the the set itself is
could be
or somewhere kind of like weirdly shaped
so that's why this z may not always be
correlated with Sigma so in the worst
case it can but you know not not always
possible so so so the so basically the
question is that you know can we
strengthen this inequality here
like why this has to be worst case
so so if you think about this right so
um
what is the if you think about it so
uh what is the soup expectation of the
so basically what you really care about
what you care about is the following so
you can take this
so let me just write down let me do a
little bit slowly so that's uh
um
so you care so you do this inequality
you first say that this is less than the
expectation of the soup
of the first term
plus the expectation of the soup of the
second term
this is because you know
um I guess we have claimed that you know
uh expectation of soup
a plus b
is always less than
uh expectation of soup
hey
plus expectation of super B
right so so the first thing you can do
is this follow and then you care about
this
and before as I said you know we have a
very worst case inequality for the inner
product but actually
this is this point itself you know may
not be like worst case right because
here Z is in this in some sense in this
ball around V Prime right so you have
this
ball v Prime here which is the which is
the ball and the Z is is in this ball
so so if this this ball is not like a
you know sometimes this Z is in the
and you can create this you can make
this a
discover you know of a certain shape so
that it is in this ball in some sense
this is the ball intersect with Q if
it's really a ball I think
you
um
uh the the worst case inequality is
tight but actually you are intersecting
this ball with the q1 Q could be weirdly
shaped so so if you look at this then
this one could still be possibly small
because you know if this uh this this
ball intersect intersect with Q is of a
small complexity
right so so so what you so basically the
idea is that what you do is that the for
the first inner thing you just do the
the log of the carbon number but for the
second thing you do another round of
like discretization
so because you don't want to say that Z
can be worst case I want to say that Z
probably cannot be worst case z has to
be have some structure so I'm going to
describe it again
sorry I I mean how do I turn this off
okay
um wait why am I why I'm having this
sorry
not bad
I'm not using my attackers right
so everyone is selector everyone was
Zoom meeting can hear me right could
could hear me right so sorry I forgot to
take off the
High School bye-bye
can you still hear me
okay I hope you can hear me okay thank
you thanks
okay cool sorry I'm back I forgot
um take off it okay so so basically the
kind of idea is that you this is still a
rather marker complexity of BB Prime in
a sec with q and and you can do another
round of this causation for this set so
that you get you know even tighter
inequality so that's kind of the the
rough idea so basically you have a
nested
um
layers of like this conversation to be
to make it stronger and stronger
so
so
that's the basic idea and now let's do a
look let's make a little more formal so
that I can
um
Define something and
uh and and explain the increasing more
so let's say we have so so I guess you
know maybe just the two
briefly draw this you know a little bit
so so what you do is you do another
disposition of this yellow ball
and then you say that
this Z cannot be worst case it has to be
something like
Z can be approximate by this plus this
I'm not sure whether this is too
I will draw a bigger figure figure but
basically this point Z is now you
approximate the Z by its nearest
neighbor again and then you look at the
difference and then your approximate
Difference by something else I'll draw
this more formally uh in a moment
so
um to do that let's define Epsilon 0 to
be
as the soup
uh over
f c over i x
Max over I
fzi so this is just the maximum possible
value that you can output and and you
can see that this is just some
preparation which is
almost trivial so you can see that
this is always
bigger than this because each entry
Epsilon is bigger than each of the fdis
and this is equals to square root of
power n the two number V Square
forever being Q
so so basically Epsilon 0 is an upper
bound
of the entire side
you have to not have to talk about any
absence bigger than this because you
know everything is in this ball of
Epsilon zero
and now I'm going to create this nested
uh all this
the technical is not nested but I think
I've always thought about it as a
message
family of like her these conditions but
technically you don't really need a
nested part so let me draw this you know
uh okay let me Define things first so
for so I'm going to
consider Epsilon 1 to be
half times absolute zero Epsilon 2 is
a culture of Epsilon zero so in general
Epsilon J is 2 to the minus J Epsilon 0.
so so these are
um the kind of like the the radius for
my Epsilon cover and let
C J B
uh and Epsilon J cover
of
the set Q of Q so I have this family of
of Epsilon covers and intuitively you
can think of
kind of think of
Epsilon J plus 1 cover like CJ is nested
in C
C J plus one is nested
in CJ in some sense but I don't but this
is not necessary for the proof
and also it's not the entire you know
but not necessary
I just like to think like that just to
give me some kind of like Chrome
um kind of intuition so so what's really
happening let me draw if I draw this
what's really happening is that I have
this set Q maybe I should enjoy a ball
so that it's kind of like more
interesting so this is the set queue and
um there is a
there's a biggest thing which is the
Epson zero which covers everything let
me now draw that so if you use the
absolute zero cover then it's trivial
because apps from zero you can just use
a trivial cover to cover you just need
one Pawn to cover everything so you just
need the origin that's not all that
let's draw uh something
maybe option one so what happens is that
you use you have a very coarse going to
cover at the beginning
something like this
right so so this is your Epson one
um and
and I have a point
this is something really hard to draw so
I need to follow my notes exactly
so that I don't have any issues with it
so I guess suppose I have a point
let's say
here
this is my point V that I want to
approximate by the cover
so suppose this is the origin
so
before what I do is that maybe let's
draw this V somewhere else sorry
maybe this will be here
so
so this is let's call this U1 this is
the closest point in the first level of
the Epson cover
so
so before I just use U1 to approximate V
and now what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to first use you one and then I
consider the second level of the Epson
cover so which is of a smaller size you
know with this of the actual size half
so whether this is by the way this this
number two is not nothing magical you
can make it like three or four it's just
for convenience you just need a constant
um constant Factor smaller
um that you know at every level
so so you have this for example right so
this is the second level
and what you do is you say I'm going to
take the point u 2 here U2 is the
nearest neighbor of v in the second
level
and then what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to approximate
V by U1 Plus
this vector
between U2 and U1
so so then I have a smaller distance
between V and U2 right so and then I'm
going to have the third level let me
I'll only draws three levels so suppose
in the third level what happens is that
you have another
thing here and this is u3
and then you also consider this Vector
between U2 and u3 so basically
approximately V by this right Vector
plus the green Vector plus the yellow
vector and then you continue to do this
until you get to be
so
any questions so far
so basically I'm going to approximately
V by U1 plus U2 minus U1
plus u3 minus U2
until Infinity because I'm going to have
like an infinite number of disk
coverings
um it doesn't have to be exactly
infinite number of them if you have fun
going enough like a approximation you
can stop but for Simplicity let's just
say we have an infinite sequence of
absent covers and you can do this so so
more formula what I'm going to do is
that for every V and Q
okay let's I guess this is just a formal
definition
so
it's it's nearest neighbor
you know wrist
neighboring CJ right so so that's why by
definition
because Uday has to be covered by CJ so
that's why so V has to be covered by CJ
so that's where V10
the distance between
u j is less than Epsilon J
um right so all in other words one over
square root and times V
cvj2 Norm is less than absolutely
and
and also because Epsilon J goes to zero
we know that u j goes to
V eventually as J goes to Infinity
J goes to the infinity
so that's why you can write this nested
sum you can write this as U1
Plus
U2 minus U1 plus u3 minus U2
so and so forth
right and if you like you use zero to be
zero then you can write this as
U1 minus u0 plus U2 minus U1
this is just a to make it looks nicer so
that we can write it as some so this is
sum of u i let's see y minus one
y for 1 to Infinity
and you can check the convergence right
if you really want right so just because
I have this
so
so if you look at the partial sum then
is
um minus u0 and because u n
this partial sum
this goes to
v as M goes to Infinity so so this could
cover and technically you actually if
you really want to have a proof and you
don't have actually have to
use use infinite sum I'm just trying to
make it simpler so you can just say I'm
going to choose the amp that is big
enough and then I pay some small error
at the end that's also fun
um
so okay so and once we do this and what
as we kind of planned
so we have this kind of like us
better and better approximation right so
now let's deal with each of these
factors
so what we have is that expectation of
the soup
this becomes expectation
terms
sum of UI minus UI minus 1 Sigma
and from 1 to Infinity
right so and then you
um switch the sum with the soup so you
get
expectation less than expectation
soup
uh
six
um
say soup
right and and then this is equals to sum
the expectation of the soup
okay so and and here the constraint is
the UI needs to be in CI and UI minus 1
needs to be in CA minus 1.
right so so in some sense this quantity
each of these quantity is kind of like
some kind of like random marker
complexity
but but this is a final class because U1
and UI minus 1 no are not arbitrary
vectors they have to come from a finance
set
and then we just have to deal with you
know we just have to see what's the
rather Market complexity of this set and
and then continue with the derivation
so
um okay so let's try to deal with each
of these terms so
so we're trying to use Masala land all
right so Masa Lemma is dealing with is
trying to deal with this kind of terms
for finance set so first of all CI so
so the combination of UI and um as well
are the variables right so they are in
CI times CMS 1. and CI times c i minus 1
the size is equals to
this the size of CI times CM as well so
this is something you you can compute
and simplify that in a moment
uh and
you can also have an by the way for
masal Lemma let's just go back real
quick
so I think we had this in the beginning
so for masalama you have to check how
large
you have to check how large the vectors
are right so so this atom doesn't matter
right if all the vectors are super big
then your complex will be big and if all
the vectors are extremely small then
your complexity will be small
so so let's check what's the value of M
here so the value m is the bound on the
two Norm of the vectors the normalized
two Norm of the vectors right so so
basically we need to check one over
squared n times
UI minus UI minus 2 2 Norm
how large this can be eventually
so uh so this can be if you up about
this this is at most
just to achieve you try and go
inequality
and
wait sorry you cannot do a triangle and
the quality that would defeat the
purpose so what I'm going to do is that
uh yeah sorry so you you are gonna do a
slightly more careful triangle and
quality because
you want to say you are an um as well
close right so so but U and UI minus
five themselves each of them could be
big if you look at this right so
U1 and U2 you know as as vectors they
are they're probably big but their
differences is small and smaller and
smaller as you have bigger and bigger
eyes and how do you control that I think
there's actually easy way you just
derive this as UI minus V because you
can always compare with v
that's something you know
right so and then use triangle
inequality because both UI minus V is
somewhat small and U1 minus one
V is somewhat small
and how small they are so you know that
the first term score well scoring times
UI minus V this is less than Epsilon I
and and the first term and the second
term is less than Epsilon I minus one
this is just by the definition of the
uh of the Epson cover
right so and Epsilon I
is 2 to the minus I times Epsilon zero
so Epsilon I is smaller than Epsilon
minus one so by a factor of two so so
this is actually three times x y
just because Epsilon minus 1 is 2 times
bigger than Epsilon
okay so with all of this preparation we
can apply the masalama then
what you have is that
soup
is less than
so we get square root 2 times the M
Square this this is the m right
so you have M Square which is 3 is
Epsilon I squared
and it has the log of the carbon number
and the covering number sorry the log of
the size of the of the set the size of
the set is CI times CM as one
and over
over n
right so and let's try to simplify this
a little bit
so you get three Epsilon I outside
over square root n and you have
square root log CI plus log c m minus 1.
and 1 times 2
and then you say that this is less than
so C so
c i
is probably bigger than it's always
bigger than CM as one because you know
CI is a more fun grained absolute cover
discretization then cms1 so if you have
more fun growing you should have more
sex more points this is just by
definition so uh so you got you just
spawn CMS 1 by CI so you get
6 Epsilon I over square root n Times
Square Root log
CI because we just replace this term by
log c i
okay so the constant doesn't really
matter that much anyways so uh
all right
so so now let's see what we have
achieved right so we have bound each of
this term and let's go back to this
formula so we just plugged it in so what
we got is that
uh so we got expectation
soup well and V Sigma this is our Target
Which is less than the sum of this over
I
I have from 1 to Infinity
6 Epsilon I overscript and square root
log CI
so this is still not really an
integration right so
um
um so how do you turn this into
integration right but this is kind of
like half a little like a flavor of the
integration you have like
you know a lot of terms right in some
sense
um so so how do we see this right so
they're they're I think the the way I
see this is the following
so
um so maybe let me just write down
what's the final formula you want to
achieve the final formula I want to
achieve is
to recall that this is something like 12
times 1 over square root 10 Times Square
Root log and Epsilon
I have L2 p and the episode and this is
the final formula we want to achieve
and by the way in some sense actually
you don't really have to get this
integration if you
if you don't if you just care about you
know applying this to some cases because
this is enough for you to apply it uh
it's just like this integration looks so
nice and it's kind of like a it's a it's
a good interface you know in in a
mathematical sense but then so so how do
you see these two are almost the same
um the way I see it is the following so
if you think about
what this integration is right so they
have up some of this
on this Dimension and let's plot the
the carbon number the cover number will
be
the log this is the law of carbon number
log maybe let's say square root
square root log
and Epsilon f l2p
so you plug this and at some point this
this carbon number will be one and so
the log of the carbon number will be
zero this is just because when you when
you read this is big enough you can just
use one thing to cover everything so the
log cabin number can be one right and
particularly in our notation
when when you read this is absolute zero
then your cover number becomes one and
the low carbon number becomes zero so
square root of that is also zero so and
and this this current number will be
going to will go to Infinity eventually
as Epsilon goes to zero
because
um you know you need more and more
points in covers as you have like a more
and more fun growing covers
so and and you have this you know
sequence of like points but so like a
you have for example option one is here
right so which is half of Epsilon zero
but let's look at Absolute I so
foreign
so suppose this is Epsilon I
and and
if this is absolute I then a half of
height will be absolute I plus one by
definition
so this is Epsilon I Plus 1.
and and what what is this value this is
value the corresponding carbon number
right so this is
square root log c i
right that's the that's our in our
notation
right so and
and now let's let's compare these two
quantities where this
this quantity and this quantity this is
what we are trying to link right so the
quantity below is just the
the error and the curve under this curve
right that's the definition of okay I
guess I'm ignoring the one with scorpion
which is you know easy right so so if
you don't have the one by square root
not the 12 right the
so so this integral is just the error on
the curve and now what's this definite
sum and if you look at the final song
then it's Epsilon
like
if you look at the
this thing
the arrow of this triangle
uh sorry it's another color this is a
rectangle my back so the area of this
rectangle then is uh the the error the
mass of the is this is Epsilon I minus
Epsilon I plus one oh times the height
which is square root log CI
and Epsilon I and Epsilon I plus 1 are
just the
this is just the
let me see what's the best I think this
is Epsilon I over 2 times
log of CI
and this is
just the multiple of this term
right so so basically the final sum is
sometimes just dealing with all of these
rectangles and the integral is doing all
everything
so so that's why the sum of the
rectangles will be smaller than the
integrals up to a constant Vector so
basically what you know is that you know
Epsilon I over 2
square root log c i because this is the
this area
is less than the integral
of this part right if this is less than
the integral of this part it's less than
integral from
Epsilon I plus 1 to Epsilon I
and square root log and Epsilon
about 2PM the Absol
okay so and with this we we can just
take sum over all eyes so it's
so you have some of Epsilon I over 2
square root log c i
it's less than
sum over I from
one to infinity infinity
right
uh sorry this is not right so and
and now you can see that this you know
each of these integral has the matching
upper bound lower bound so you got this
is from zero to absolute zero
square root log and Epsilon
2 P.M
the abso
and the upper bond is still not
infinitive but that doesn't really
matter because this really literally
just equals to
you can extend it to Infinity because
everything Beyond Epsilon zero bigger
than Epsilon zero will be
zero so
that's what we have
okay so now you just if you just
multiply
this is the essential thing right so
using the with this inequality you just
link these two quantities you know so I
think you just have to work out the
constantly I think there's a constant
two there so that's why it gets from 6
to 12. so with this you get expectation
and this is actually the rather Market
complexity of f is equals to this
is less than
basically what six Epsilon I over
squared and
square root log c i and this is less
than 12 times this integral
Okay so
any questions
okay great so
okay so and and I think from this figure
you can also kind of see that you know
in some sense the essence here is that
how fast
Epsilon goes to Infinity that's what's
important here right because if Epsilon
goes to Infinity very fast then your
integration probably could be even
Infinity so then you don't have any bot
and if your uh if this thing goes to
Infinity
like here slower than you get available
yeah so the question is like oh I chose
this uh level like a fact of two right
so like it's 2 to the minus J times
Epsilon zero so what if I change that
two to three or something like that I I
never tried that myself but I think
um very very likely you would just get a
similar constant maybe you get better
than 12 maybe you get worse than 12 but
anyway this constant is not that
important for us so but I
I think it's very unlikely you can gain
anything by
like you can gain anything more than a
constant
okay so now let's let's try to interpret
this theorem a little bit more
because in some sense this serum you
know like this form is kind of hard to
use right so because you know if I got
the log carbon number bound
and okay what's the internal use of this
here so the the way to use this Serum is
that you you get some low carbon number
bound and then you do this integral you
get the random marker complexity
right so but uh but it's kind of like
hard to use it because you know before
you get the so you don't know how how
does this translation work you know
especially but actually the translations
from the carbon number to the right
number complex actually it's actually
relatively simple as as I will show so
this integration doesn't have
like you you see like actually you don't
even need to
like like I never complete this integral
myself like after I don't once in some
sense okay so here's how it works
so so for the um
so
Yeah so basically the question is when
this is finance right so when this is
this thing is finance
and and when it's Finance you know
what's the dependency right so and so
forth
so when
it's finite
so I think there are several cases like
let's do kind of this is a case study so
it of course it depends on what the law
cover number will be so we have I have a
few cases here so a
if
the covering number is exponential in
absolute
is of the form
um is of the form something like one
over Epsilon to the power
some power R is just a variable like
placeholder
so suppose it's expensive in the sense
that one of the Epsilon is in the base
then you can do this computation you get
and this is equals to something like
on
small over squared and
square root R log y rhapsulin
right so just because you take a low
carbon number and and you will see that
and you take the absolute
and you'll see that the log one graphs
don't integrate to some constant
uh from zero to Infinity
oh by the way I think maybe I should say
I I forgot to take a yes
uh
there's a small thing like I don't want
to always integrate from 0 to Infinity
because that sometimes it's actually
annoying so
I forgot to mention this so let's assume
that the ifs bonnet
between let's say
minus one one
so that
this integral only I have to do you only
have to do it in between 0 and infinity
so like
apps on zero let's say it's one
something like this or maybe a constant
so we only have to
to integrate between 0 to 1 let's say
right so so this is just because you
have a bonding function after that like
the log cabin number because it becomes
zero
and now let's integrate going back to
this we integrate between 0 and 1 is log
one over Epsilon and you'll see that you
know this log one website will actually
integrates to something a strictly a
constant so this will be
um just the o
maybe let's write in one notation I
should write this like
and this is just an order of like square
root R over n
because the absolute integrals to a
constant the dependency of absolute is
called
okay so so that's good so you get this
thing and
let's look at another case so this is
actually a case where the dependence on
absence is very very mild because it's a
lot more radical so that's why it's
pretty mild
and but sometimes you never get you
don't get this so so if
it's an absolute f l two p n
is of the form
a to the Epsilon R over Epsilon so now
the absent is in exponent
um
um but um yeah and that's and and it's
one of absolute exponents and in this
case if you look at this
more of a square root and
integral
slow cover number
this will be well squared n
R over Epsilon squared algorithm log a
right
so
and this is still
so
the episode and and still square root
one of our apps on this integrates to
one
the Epson this is a constant
a universal constant you can
I guess we don't care about constantly
so it's some constant
um and this is equals to so basically if
you ignore the log Factor this is equal
to our
so still of this form
that's still good and now it comes to
the the trickiest thing which is kind of
like it's on a kind of on a boundary
between what we can do and what we
cannot do
so if this is of the form something like
a to the r over Epsilon Square so now I
have a
even worse dependency on Epson right so
it's in exponent and also is one webs
from Square so it goes to Infinity as
Epsilon goes to zero faster
so and in this case this becomes a
little bit tricky because and but
actually this is the most common case
right if you if you really do the work
you know I don't really expect you to
prove financialization about yourself
um
um you know that that often like but if
you really do the work in many of the
cases you get this kind of like cover
number so and this is actually tricky
because if you integrate
uh the thing
what you get is that
uh
uh you take the log of this and you take
square root so what you get is maybe
let's
you get
square root R times one over Epsilon
uh Times Square Root log a
right so this is the App Store
so this is called r squared log a square
root and
one of our apps on the Epson and this
this thing is actually Infinity
um I guess this is because the
how do you see this like a wall of
absolute integers to log I have some
undone log absolute zero is infinity so
this goes to Infinity too fast at zero
so that it integrates to Infinity
so so this is actually you know this is
not a good news for us right so so how
do we but actually this can be fixed uh
how do we fix this so this can be fixed
by our improved version
of at least here and this improved
version in some sense you know I'm not
going to prove it but it actually is
kind of like almost
expected so what you can show is that so
basically the idea is that you don't
to do the discretization all the way to
zero you do it until certain levels that
you can pay the the worst case Bond
so basically you you do it only to the
level of alpha
so you buy it by this
I think there's a actually I'm not sure
whether there's a two here but let me
have the two here anyway
so that for safety
and with a constant it's not very
important
so basically when you do the integration
you are not integrating from zero to
Infinity you are integrating from alpha
to infinity and Below Alpha you just pay
this Alpha bound so in some sense you
can see that this is the interpolation
of the two bonds we had right so recall
that one Bond we had was this wood force
increa brute forcing
where
we pay this Epsilon
like right so this is just because we
have a worst case Bound for the for the
Epson error
and and the other case we had this
integration we don't pay anything in the
worst case and this is basically saying
that
you do this nested or iterative
discretization to offer and then you pay
a small error offer at the end
um
and
and why this is useful this is useful
because you know it kind of like avoid
this cheeky regime where you are very
very close to zero so what you can do is
that
like I think this theorem you can
probably prove it yourself so I'm not
going to so the proof
um so and if you use it so you can take
Alpha to be something like one over poly
poly and
so something super super small
right so and so that it's four Alpha so
that for Alpha
is negligible
and and so that you hear on the right
hand side you don't integrate to
Infinity
so so basically four Alpha is in English
one question is what integration
uh or the integration look like so this
is something like
inverse portion
which is negligible and then you have
square root R square root log a
square root n and you integrate between
Alpha and one and you have one over up
so well over Epsilon D Epsilon
and unfortunately this one
even though it goes to Infinity as Alpha
absent goes to zero
like a as Alpha go to zero but this is
actually something that depends on Alpha
very
very weekly so
so this is this right
I'm not surviving this system
you know what my rotation means right
sometimes I think in different calculus
look I see different notations for this
so so sometimes I got confused
so and now this thing is really just a
times uh
this is like a log one which is zero and
minus log Alpha so you get log 1 over
Alpha
and this is logarithmaking Alpha so the
alpha is pulling in so this is
logarithmic
so this is login
so so basically eventually this is still
o till the
squared r over square rooted if you hide
all the logarithmic Factor
okay so in summary
so
so the covering number
of the form
while the options to the r
a to the r over Epsilon a to the r over
Epsilon Square only to some old leads to
something like a random marker
complexible
this form
and these are probably basically the
pretty much the only cases I I know of
that can lead to this like for example
if you suppose hypothetically
your current number is something like a
to the alpha r r over Epsilon Cube
I think this will uh will break
um
because
so
so here if this is absent Cube and I
think here it's going to be absence to
1.5 1 wraps up to 1.5
and when it's up so maybe let's do a
quick characteristic so suppose this
apps on to the 1.5
and of course you still have to
integrate from alpha so that you don't
you try to avoid the blow up right so
but it wouldn't be as effective because
12 apps onto the 1.5
this the integration of this is
I think 1 over square with Epsilon is
that log absolute
and I think this will be
um
1 minus y squared Alpha
I think it did
yeah okay there's a minus here I think
right so
so it's going to be something like 1
over square root of
minus what something like this maybe
there's a half here
yeah
anyway let's let's see ignore the
constants I don't know what the constant
is but but the problem is that this is
not log of like this one over Square
Alpha so and now you cannot take Alpha
to be poly inverse poly and because if
it's inverse polygen you you pay too
much here
so and so so then it's got it's going to
be a very tricky balance between
this fall off a term and under this term
right and I think
at least I'm not aware of any cases
where you can balance them in a nice way
so that you get still a good Bond
um I think it's gonna be probably not
even possible
um and but on the other hand you know
for the case when you have this thing
right this is log whatever Alpha here so
the balance is Trivial it's kind of like
your free lunch if you pay a lot of
factors so so it's almost always
possible right so
so that's the uh that's the difference
um
right and and actually most typically
you're gonna get some cover number of
this form that's that's the most typical
cases
okay any questions
okay so now I have 15 minutes today so
um so the the rough plan for the for the
next the rest of the 15 minutes and the
next lecture is that we are gonna talk
about hovering number Bound for linear
models and deepness and those will imply
about the marker complexity bonds and I
think today I'm going to talk about
linear models but for linear models I'm
not going to give you the proof because
I think the proof is a little bit too
technical
um in most of the cases you wouldn't you
need to use prove it yourself you just
have to invoke it so basically I'm just
gonna
um
I'm going to just State some theorems
and tell you that actually for linear
models this is almost
a kind of well I think it's kind of
almost all done like you know everything
about it and I think they are
pretty much like
matching upper bound lower bounds
so this is actually from a paper by Tong
Jong in 2012 sorry 2002 2002
so
um so it's saying that this is for Lee
for linear models
so
linear models
so
yeah so so Suppose there are
X1 up to X N and RD
are n data points
and P and Q is this so-called conjugate
pairs
I guess I hope that probably you have
seen this kind of things in order
inequalities if one one over P plus 1
over Q is equals to one
and also we also assume that
he is
better than two and less than infinity
but in most places you just can think of
p and Q are both 2 that's the most
important thing
and assume that
the P Norm of X is less than c for every
I
and then let's consider this hypothesis
because I've
indexed by Q
so this is the family of linear models
where
the norm of the linear model is bounded
by B
right recall that we have actually
talked about these kind of models
wherever p is 2 and Q is 2 or maybe p is
one Q is infinity this kind of things so
and then before we prove the random are
complexity Bond and now we prove the the
carbon number bond which will also give
a random marker complexity bound and and
this row
is equals to l2pn L2 PN this is the same
thing as we have defined before
and then
the law covering number
Epsilon
fq
sorry
times row
is less than
b square C Square
over Epsilon Square
sailing the saving doesn't matter it's
just trying to deal with the corner
cases where this is like zero or
something like that
so I would log to 2D plus one
so
and when P so and when p is 2 Q is 2
you can strengthen this construction
this
slightly
to something like log
and Epsilon F2 row
is less than b square C Square over
Epsilon Square
times the log 2
I guess the the base is also that's
important because it's only change the
constant it's just that corporate
from the base of the log doesn't really
matter that much
I'm probably here just for the sake of
preciseness so you can you can improve
the B definitely do something that
depends on and already which doesn't
matter that much
um at least for our purpose you know for
for the
for other cases you if you care about
the bond that absolutely doesn't depend
on D then this is this matters otherwise
it doesn't matter that much
Okay so
so
and and the way to remember this is just
that this gives the same random Market
complexity right so basically if you
um use the discussion above
is the the conversion above right we
have done
so this is of the form which form this
is of the form
this thing
right a to the r over F sub square right
because
here you have a log right like after
taking a log is our Epsilon Square
and the r is B Star Square C Square so
so even this conversion you got that the
rather Market complexity
is less than
square root R over n and where R is b
square c squared
so this is b c over square root
um up to
logarithmic Factor
and this was very similar to this is the
same signals we have them
before right so B was the norm of the
classifier and C was the norm of the on
the data so you get the multiplication
of them and over square rooted
so there's some small differences in
terms of the logarithm manufacturer so
which Let's ignore just for Simplicity
okay and
you can also you can also show this
formatively your models
um sorry multivarity multi varied
linear functions
and I'm showing this just because this
will be useful as a building block
a speeding block of our future
because uh when you have like a lead
when you have new networks you know a
linear and multivariate linear model is
a building block for a layer of network
um and this in some sense there's
nothing really intelligent here is but I
just have to State it so that I can use
it later so so suppose you have okay
first I have a decimal definition
so definition so suppose and is a matrix
of let's form
and the Iron by n Matrix
let's define the true Norm 2 to 2 comma
1 Norm this is not the operating Norm
this is the just some
some arbitrary Norm so this is the two
comma one Norm which is the sum
of the two Norm of the columns
[Music]
yeah
so I'm I is of Dimension and
and and you take this so basically you
first take the
two Norm of the column and then you take
the one Norm
to to group them
right so and and then
you know in this definition I'm
transposed to a norm
this is basically the Sun
of the two norms
of rows
of that
this is just definition and then we're
going to use this in the statement
so here is a theorem
a theorem is that if you consider
here I'm not going to do a p and Q just
for Simplicity
so you just to do the two Norm version
so p and Q are both two so you consider
the multivariate uh function with output
multiple outputs
um and this W let's say of Dimension n
by D
and let's constrain the W the two to one
Norm of w to be less than b
so and again let's see to be the average
of the norm of the data
and then you got
log
and
Epsilon f
L to p n
is less than
c squared B squared
over Epsilon Square
log log into D times m
so so it's kind of the same thing the
norm of the parameter times the norm of
the data over Epsilon Square on by the
norm of the parameter is measured by
this two to one Norm or sorry two two
number of w transpose
I think I think I have typo here
so what's the two to one Norm of w
transpose as I said is the sum of the
two Norms of the rows of w
so
so in some sense there is nothing
surprising here in some sense you just
glue all the dimensions like you just
treat all Dimension independently in
some sense like like for example if you
think about suppose you try w
Let's see different color
suppose you write w as W1 transpose up
to WM transpose where you have I'm
uh vectors row vectors and then w x is
really just you multiply W1 transpose
with X up to W M transpose X
so you can view this you know linear
layer as you know I'm Different linear
functions one-dimensional linear
functions and then the two
to one Norm of
is just the sum of the w i to Norm
so in some sense you just sum that you
take the sum of the complex dimension
sum of complex dimensions
of each of the model wi transpose X
right so wi is two normally is the
complex measure of the linear function
and you take the sum
so the proof is actually just
yeah there's nothing
um
I think I have five minutes let me also
mention another thing which is useful
for preparation for the deepness
so this is also related to how to do how
do we deal with bounding the law
covering them the carbon number so you
can also have the Ellipsis composition
this is a useful tool for us to do deal
with the cover numbers and this is
actually
recall that you know we had this
telegram Lemma right so
if I had the telegram Lemma which was
like for the rider marker complexity
right so you say something like the
random marker complex of fee composed
with h is less than
some lipsiousness of V times the rather
Markle complexity
of it something like this so this this
was the lipstick compensation for rather
marker complexity and that turns out
that for log covering number
the latest composition is eventually
this the telegram level I didn't prove
it for you I just say this is a fact
this is a theorem and actually proving
it doesn't
doesn't sound easy like as I mentioned
like it's actually sometimes pretty
complicated it's pretty
it's I think it's a challenging theorem
to prove
um and here the lipsense composition it
becomes trivial for covering number
um
um yeah I think the the fundamental
intuition of the spirit is the same it's
just for cover number somehow this
becomes super
intuitive and explicit like so the
let me stay dilemma but um
so this is almost a trivial thing so
suppose
fee is Kappa ellipsis
and then and let's say row is this
output Norm
thing like then
a low cover number of fee absolute fee
composed with f
like I messed up my order of these
arguments like in my notes like for
every occurrences after certain points
so so I have to fix it later so
um
so Epsilon so if you look at the low
carbon number of the composed function
class V composed with F this is less
than
the low carbon number of
of the original one but you have a
different radius or different
um granularity
so you basically have to cover the
original one with absolute over copper
granularity so that you can turn that
into a cover
Epsilon cover of the new composed
function and this is pretty much just
tribute because if you just take
I guess I'll just take Epsom over Kappa
cover
for f
and then
like then
so suppose this is thick
that's called C
and then
free composed with c
it I climate is option cover
of V composed with f
so because
just for every
composed with f in
this class
you can just First Take F find F Prime
in C
such that
um
this video I have F Prime is less than
absolute so your first one is covered
um in C and then you just compose it so
if we compose with f Prime I claim that
this is actually a neighbor of B
composed with F this is because if you
look at distance between this
two thing this is um
square root one over n sum of
C of f Prime z i minus field FCI
and you use the ellipsislessness so this
is
less than water and times Kappa Square
and then because F Prime and F are absor
over copper close so this is copper
times Epsilon over Kappa
it's absolute
so so we're done
um
yeah so
okay I guess that's a that's a good
stopping point
um and we'll continue next to the next
lecture about weakness
cool any questions
yeah yeah so I should yes that's right
the Ellipsis
[Music]
yeah so so far I have actually a
one-dimensional function fee is a
randomized something right I have
outputs wonder myself thing and then you
have a one to one R to R function fee so
so there's no magic but yes but if I
have output is a vector and then your
fee is a vector to Vector function then
you have to make the norm
everything compatible the Ellipsis this
has to
be the same thing compatible with the
norm
s
[Music]
yes yes so we're going to use just out
um
okay okay sounds good okay I guess I'll
see you
on Wednesday